and uh joe an interesting development on
italy and uh quarantine
yeah if you plan to go on holiday to uh
italy in the next few days mark not good
news
grant shap the transport secretary has
tweeted in the last few minutes and this
is what he has written travel corridor
update we are removing italy
vatican city estate and san marino from
the travel corridor list
however note that the implementation
date is moved to 4 am on sunday the 18th
of october
and applies uk wide if you arrive from
those
these destinations you will need to
self-isolate so italy
is off the quarantine exemption list
along with the vatican city in san
marino
that of course means that if you were
planning to travel there or if you are
there if you don't get back
by 4 a.m on sunday you will need to
quarantine
uh for two weeks of course it does seem
to be a slight
change in the timing here mark the fact
that it's 4 a.m on sunday not 4 a.m on
saturday
suggests they realize many holidays are
booked saturday to saturday
so the people coming to the at the end
of their uh holidays in italy
perhaps on saturday they will be able to
conclude them as planned without being
caught up
in these further coronavirus measures